now right hold on wait wait I'll do it
I'll do a sitting I'll do a hand signal
see no we're good
all right and we are live the last word
with a bot is whoo we got some Luda
shooters to talk about it it's pretty
good
we got a workout in this morning so kind
of got my the day started right so
feeling good I went to go see John wick
last night with a nice little early
viewing so starting this thing off
positive shout out to Keanu Reeves man
like he was born for two roles
well maybe three with Bill and Ted but
like neo and then the the work they do
in John wicks like I know there's a
stunt double in there and I know he put
in some work as well but man that is
like the ultimate you have Avengers
action which is its own animal of like
crazy huge battle battle scenes and then
you have one guy against the world and
it's just amazing to watch I saw an IMAX
so like epic sounds that guns so much
fun so I just wanted to start with that
to be positive and also thank you guys
for hey we just starting it out but I
also wanted to shout out to just to
thank you guys so gonna start actually
having a couple as in there so you guys
may have actually seen one in the
beginning so gonna have a couple trying
to get a little support for this one and
also I will have a link at just in the
description and things like that with
regards to the podcast itself so there's
a link where you guys can actually go
and help support the podcast if you want
to never acquired but always appreciate
it so thank you guys just for all the
support coming to hang out with us but
if you want to help support our causes
well it is greatly appreciated and thank
you for starting this morning out with a
follow and a sub Thank You bender for
two months as well so he's kind of
getting all the little pre work out of
the way and Wow
so we're just gonna basically jump into
the world of destiny to this morning
because the swap dropped and the
internet exploded at least that has any
relation to destiny to and oh my oh I
don't even know where to start
I really don't
we're just gonna work our way down the
[ __ ] but this is just kind of turned
into a basically a giant discussion so
[ __ ] dropped yesterday I don't know if
it's like five or six it was before I
was getting ready to go to the movie and
then like got a quick brief look and
then had some food and then was sitting
them but in the movie just like
beforehand like just ridiculously like
not understanding everything that's
going on yeah if you've been living
under the rock for about the past 12
hours things are changing in season whap
you-let's is the nicest nicest way I can
phrase that things are things are
changing so first piece on the 12-yard
banners going on better right now
because that's that's really not a big
deal anymore season of opulent sandbox
changes we're just diving straight in
not wasting any time baby toy so I'm
gonna start and we're gonna stop kind of
on each weapon as we go through however
kind of points a discussion and then
we'll kind of when we get through each
piece so let's even just try and focus
on each one first and then we'll just
kind of get to an overall discussion
this is gonna be the big topic today
there's gonna be some stuff going back
and forth so chat feel free to be live
and and just keep it clean clean oh we
gotta put a disclaimer out after this is
clean but I do actually want to see your
guys opinions and thoughts in there so
feel free to chat comment things like
that so we're gonna just kind of go
through this piece by piece so I'm gonna
read some of this verbatim just so I can
kind of stay objective and reading it
and then we're gonna go off the off the
rails a bit season of opulence is fat is
on fast approach and similar to past
seasons and sandbox changes will arrive
with it last week we set your sights on
a new raid that begins on June 4th the
same day that the new season launches we
wanted to let you know what to expect
from the sandbox so you can plan
accordingly the Destiny dev team has the
details for season of opulence several
notable weapons are being adjusted we
want to ensure that encounters raids and
other in-game content for example
remains a challenge some of these
weapons have been overwhelming that
challenge our first choice is to buff
underused weapons hmm but if we continue
to push every weapon up higher and
higher it will be impossible to maintain
challenging experiences this is not a
full list of changes but some of the
most impact
so before we get into any specifics I
want to ask like right there just about
some of those lines so some of the
weapons have been overwhelming the
challenge right our first choice is both
of he's gonna say and this one kind of
goes to the next one our first choice is
to buff under used weapons but if we
continue to push every weapon up higher
and higher it will be impossible to
maintain challenging experiences so what
do you think of just those two I'll be
honest um I do not I'm not as upset with
that statement to some degree um but
buffing under use weapons should be a
priority you know I'm saying like
roughing you know that that is a big
problem and um damn I want to go in but
I'm gonna try to hold the shrimp because
my um piece at a time I'm trying to keep
it cool yeah I'll try to keep it off
trying to keep it together
um yes there is some truth that you know
you definitely if you buff everything
you know that you know obviously things
can get out of control but at the same
time based on the history of destiny and
what we seen with the meta you know they
tend to skew towards you know the nerf
of what is first the nerf like the
nerfing of high usage rate weapons and
this is where it seems where it going so
I'll leave it at that for now yeah
so yeah I'm just gonna try and do this
in little segments and some we're gonna
explode don't worry working there but
yeah it's like some of the weapons have
been overwhelming the challenge so part
of my issue is some of these that they
some of these that they discuss-- are
not new so some of these are the things
they've known about they've been through
some of these thoughts before they try
and figure out the best way to make this
there's a very specific line at some
point that arcs me a lot we'll get to it
a little bit later dynamo but as you as
you say our first choice is to buff
under use weapons and that is one of
those things that really needs to get
looked at because somebody said there's
a lot of people I'm gonna reference on
Twitter there's no way in the world I'm
gonna remember them all today so shout
out to some of them likes Caroline who
was a guest on here before
dude who fell out plays of course
awesome man of science he's out there
host doing the shout casting for the
gambit tournament by the way I want to
shout out the car guys go all out go
follow him and go watch that man shout
cast this gambit tournament out there
over in the UK that's gonna be awesome
actually I was so cool scientist yeah
just the random once I caught glimpses
up in the past 12 hours was like Chevy
and say no to rage and gigs and like so
many people out there you're just
watching this like now sometimes there
are people and all those people I list
are gonna be some of the upper echelon I
mean you've got fallout who's awesome at
PvP you've got you know gigs you've got
glad you've got people like that who are
awesome in PvP do these what challenges
and things like that and then get to the
point where they use some of these
weapons to like an extreme level but
they are also ultra high skilled you
take like the 10% and you build a
sandbox around them the other 90% who
already don't find any of this game to
be like a cakewalk right are gonna be in
struggling even more if you take some of
these tools away that give them some
some breadth of hope some life in some
of their game where they get to have
some fun so the fact that like they're
almost steering some of the sandbox and
this is one of those things the vision
did once the vision one they like well
des streamers were you know getting so
much currency and working on this and
they buffed the cost of some things up
so high the only people who could really
actually still do what they needed to do
or the ones who have already had so much
in the first place so my worry is some
of the fact that now they're trying to
skew towards almost the hardcore too far
to balance it again and the other people
aren't even gonna have a chance so um I
get it you're not you're not wrong I
don't think you're wrong and what you're
saying um again I want to shout out
what's my guy we had him on man um doc
yeah my boy doc yeah and you know we had
him on when we had him during the Dead
destiny face you know I'm saying and
everything he missed and um he made some
key points in reference to how Bungie
works and it they're very adamant
they're very statistic based so yes I do
agree that they don't like you know guys
like that glass and all that stuff who's
doing all that stuff
but I get the sense they're strictly
number driven
and they're looking at their chart and
like I said good ol usage rate and
they're like oh no you know I'm saying
whereas what we were saying we got to go
for under you stuff as well you know so
we have to put that same energy towards
under you stuff but let's get to it
there we go all right so the first
target on the chopping block
[Laughter]
Whisperer the worm now this is my baby I
feel you bro I was like anyway this is
you this is you let me let you set this
be okay there's mold this gate this gun
has been around since crota start I
don't even remember the name it was
black spindle and then black I feel like
it had to not have slack like hammer
okay mm-hmm and then came back his black
spindle or something right mm-hmm so
this gun has been around for quite a
while then they make a hell of a quest
like an amazing mission one of my
favorites of the entire destiny
experience for all five years and they
bring the gun back in its original form
so basically what happened was you had
black hammer come out had white nail
could create its ammo if you were
skilled you could have the infinite ammo
they took it away for a year - they
brought it back and then they basically
made it to where they nerfed it and it
could no longer create that infinite
ammo situation that was destiny one then
you give us destiny - it's not here it
gets leaks you have this amazing mission
you go through the her--let catalyst you
do it three times
shout out to the million of you guys who
watch the damn video or at least all of
that stuff for mommy oh man seriously
that was one of my biggest things ever
but that I mean even for me and I'm not
the biggest video out there there are
multiple people bigger than theirs so
there's a lot of appeal to this and many
people have been through the journey to
get whisper so you know it's a big deal
and for them to have been through and
destiny want both versions of that
weapon and shout out to the drifter with
the tier one sub for six months thank
you very much by the way you gotta shout
that out
when they ask YouTube they've been
through both versions of the weapon in
d1 they bring it back in original form
indeed - and they're like okay they had
to have gone through the thoughts they'd
been through it before somebody at
Bungie has been there long enough to
know how this is gonna go so this is
what's going on for season of opulence
whisper the worm was already adjusted in
season two The Drifter but an exotic
that can generate an infinite amount of
heavy ammo is still a gigantic outlier
and renders mini weapons are relevant
for certain encounters while exotics
aren't tended to be powerful and novel
bypassing the ammo economy can tend to
force us to adjust enemies to compensate
this effectively results in sniper
rifles as a whole being punished because
of whispers unique ammo ability as a
result removing the ammo generation
ability so that we can increase the
effectiveness of all other snipers that
don't have an endless ammo supply to
bullet points white nail pulls ammo from
reserves rather than creating it reserve
ammo is back up to 18 without ammo perks
so I think it's gonna be like 21 or 24
with perks whatever it was before
yeah but the biggest thing is they're
taking away basically white nail they're
taking away what makes whisper or black
camp black spindle whichever one that
was the original they're taking away
what makes it an exotic and honestly at
this point you take something like
whisper that is a sniper rifle it hits
hard that's fine it's got three in the
clip but what is what makes that weapon
in exotic its ability to generate ammo
now literally all you've done is turned
it into a Luna faction boots or rally
barricade sniper rifle and that is it it
doesn't have explosive rounds it doesn't
have you know hit three shots and then
you it has whisper breathing for the
extra damage but that's honestly just
the same as the single shot and I'm
surprised they didn't turf that too but
you take a sniper like that that can
continue to make ammo if you're skilled
and honestly with the flinching enough
believe me I still run out of ammo with
that weapon it's not like I'm going
through and oh cool I can hit all my
shots you missed one you're like crap
there's a clip so late yeah I was like
I'm I'm hurting right now so it's like
want to get your thoughts this is kind
of that's what happened with the weapon
so tell me your thoughts on it at this
point
this is tough I was surprised by this
because um we already you know we
already got the previous whisper unless
we capped that what was the previous one
they had uh but it was an ammo count
right yeah so they took the reserves
they're basically going back to what it
was so it had 18 in reserves if you wore
like double reserve armor say like I
think it's the helm in the class item
that can do it you could bump it up to
at least 21 I think at least 21 maybe a
little more so you can have a lot of
shots but if you're wearing double
sniper reserves for ammo you're very
light you're committed to a sniper so
what they did recently is they drop the
ammo reserve count to nine so they
basically cut it in half and then said
if you're wearing double a more reserved
perks you can get 12 mm-hmm which was a
pretty big hit because I mean Darcy for
example has like 23 you can have almost
like 28 bullets with that buddy oh yeah
so like as a sniper that still needs to
like hit stuff let's not like
Wardenclyffe coil that does 6000 damage
of one rocket shot like yeah so they
nurse the ammo count so you had even a
lot smaller margin for error right yeah
I mean this is this is tough because
again the way I look at it is also the
effort required to get said weapon right
this was at its time one of the hardest
challenges to loot to get that weapon so
we went to one earth okay we go to the
second earth now you basically take the
essence of what whisper is right which
is pulling that ammo from reserve you
know and again to me just seems like and
and I'm gonna say there's gonna be my
reoccurring theme as we go under which
is all of this feels to me in
preparation for season of opulence and
the vibe I get is besides usage rate
they're looking at the array they're
looking at whatever their high-level
content is and this is public enemy
number one because the way again I'm not
agreeing I'm just putting you in the
mentality of but ya know their mentality
is we don't want you burning through our
content
right this is been criminally charged
with resident clearly wet white male in
their opinion is criminally charged for
blasting through their content so I get
it you know III understand why the
problem is you just nerfed it now you're
nerfing it again now you're taking the
essence of what it is you know to force
the action and I kind of feel a way
about that and I'm not even the sniper I
am NOT the whisper guy like to be honest
not to get the weapons amazing always
has been you know I'm saying I'm gonna
take nothing away from it but at the
same time you have to do something
better than this you can't take what
makes it it in my opinion it's such a
great iconic weapon and then you brought
it back remember he they brought it back
as an exotic right yeah initially it was
black hammer right now Oh too much to be
you know running with this and
Gjallarhorn okay I got you yeah it was a
legendary with Galatea totally forgot
about that yeah it was I remember I said
you know what I respect it cuz everybody
had their save loadout fate bringing
black hell yeah so I get it listen in in
balance and fairness the only thing I
will give them with this nerf and it's a
very small thing is usage rate I'm
assuming whisper is still up there I
mean we know is adonys up there as far
as power we know sleeper kinda is that
we gonna get it to that you know I'm
saying but did the fact though I would
probably say is whisper you would say
and they're happy what would you say is
the most destiny to right now what would
you say is the most popular have in
fairness I made you give a PvE stuff
yeah whisper whisper is definitely like
top three minimum like it's probably a
top two I'm there's probably something I
mean there's point where like for yeah
I'm blinking on last wish raid boss
right now um OH ribbon ribbon like you
press the rack prospect well no like
even clusters as they say and prospector
just dump it and she's dead like so I
mean there are different options but
whisper has been and still is it is a
very powerful weapon but it is the point
it is powerful in a skilled persons hand
you put
to a potato aim it's a useless slow
reloading like it's not gonna do that
much like so I mean that's me but that's
the that's part of the issue is like it
is a skilled weapon and you take I may
be used by a lot of people but I want to
know the people who like how many people
and this would be a really hard thing
for them to track but how many people
like in one set encounter ear in 3060
seconds can sit there and generate the
ammo like perfectly I want to know the
people at that skill level he'll do it a
lot like some boss heads are bigger than
others obviously so it's bigger but I
mean yeah it's used on a lot of
encounters but as you said you're taking
away I don't have anybody seen the
friends episode where Joey takes the
essence yeah the essence of the chair it
was like Coco sure you're taking the
cushions I'm taking the essence they're
literally taking what makes whisper
whisper away and as and that's not
somebody said it on Twitter I can't
remember who you take a weapon and you
just turned it into a sniper rifle that
functions the way every other sniper
rifle does now if you sit in a whiffed
or a rift or rally barricade or anything
like that
like it does not function any different
now so what makes it exotic where is its
exoticness you have stuff that has box
breathing is what is whispered breathing
basically just with a little tweak and
then you have your reload ability that
comes now from just other abilities
mm-hmm no you're right EU r I feel for
you on this one bro like I know how much
you love this weapon and it's not what
it is it's it's literally the SSID I'm
shoutout my boy um Josh Brener agent of
fraud we had a mobile for roasting great
enough testing pieces kind of plug Lords
gave me that in it no they gave me that
net make sure you go check it out y'all
absolutely oh you're out the frost cuz
me and we talk in and he woke up you
know to my article about all the nerves
right I don't put it up today this
morning and he was like holy hell Bungie
what is wrong which like he was like he
couldn't believe it like I can't believe
I'm waking up to this and he's like he
said what you said he's such a skilled
weapon he said another alternative and
he mentioned something effective like
why can't they just like make it like
where you get on instead of like the
infinite and make it a true skill weapon
in a sense of like you don't give it
only three shots there's no room for
error
if you want to use as far
as getting getting it back or something
like that as opposed to completely
removing right now and I'm like you know
what that's a good option I mean there's
to me so many other things they could
have done delays like this is just like
rape them right it's so that's that's
one excuse me but like that from a
devil's advocate perspective right they
have to be looking at boss and this is a
point of game design at this point and I
know believe me like making any of this
stuff is tough
whether you stop making it spongy or
whatever you do your times to light your
ways to combat what this gun does can be
a difficult thing right but why the
hell'd you bring it back in the first
place right and why did you just nerf it
again this is contact gating bro like
this is this is yeah it's just what it
is we got a call alright because again
they just told us it was too powerful
and we're gonna do that so now it's too
powerful again we're gonna do this so
it's like you know at the end of the day
this is on them this is on them and um
you know don't necessarily agree with
this one I think there were definitely
some options they could have some past
they could have taken instead of going
this extreme Wood Whisperer and you know
if they want to affect usage rate this
is how you're gonna do it because I will
see how many people continue to use it
the way you know currently my video
views will be like so okay so before
yeah before you get all too general what
right now we're talking about next one
this is your baby you notice me let me
grab is amigo you go cuz the disrespect
the disrespect let me go alright sleeper
simulant my baby the reduction of
bounced shot damage for sleeper simulant
is already present on several important
enemies we are now making this reduction
part of the weapon the difference in
damage is too large between a single
precision shot of sleeper simulant and
an angle shot that pierces the target
and then also hits the target again with
the bounced projectiles much like
whisper we've had to adjust and
around that potential by making these
changes a permanent part of the weapon
we can get it into a more balanced
position and here are the points reduced
ricochet bounce damage on boss
combatants modified precision behavior
total damages unchanged
but non precision shots are
significantly more forgiving I got major
issues let me know you know feel about
sleeper this gun is extremely difficult
to get well I should say that in the
beginning it's like it's what I'm the
catalyst catalyst is extremely difficult
to get you literally have to get all
three I closed weapons do all this
nonsense whip to set weapons do the
whisper thing get then get this in
insane amount of shots with the sleeper
listen who's using sleeper like that I'm
still shocked because we just went we
just went through the gambit stuff
remember yeah it got destroyed soon as
gambit came out they saw sleeper they
were like no no no meanwhile Queens
Baker running around loose but we get
into that we know we gonna get off that
but at the end of the day sleeper I'm
just like who's using angle shots like
this in the community like I don't know
about you maybe my data is very what is
it acid or like a mess and it or exact
thank you for I knew is gonna correct us
[Laughter]
I don't know about you I'm not seeing
fire teams running around with sleeper
using angled shots and melting bosses
really not that no we use the footage
act like ways the high tier guys that
I'm like they like notice what you do
for Calais this is what you do you shoot
the flow like who's doing this angle on
some of that stuff it's rare that you
have an angle that you're actually high
ground on a boss they're usually odd row
yeah oh nothing to shout the track Aloha
he says he's using it dragon look could
you please tell me where you're using it
that it's again I'm not going to be
funny I'm not trying to disrespect like
show me like place
is where y'all using it and it is like
so effective that it's the number one
option for you and heavy and then
reminds remember e we just got the ammo
nerf severe ammo nerves you don't say it
like a forest reserves right mm-hmm
didn't like I said the gambit even per
brick when a pickup is lower you know
say week and then we got accuracy
reduction remember that it's like this
gun every month is getting hit with
something like I've never seen a gun
just can get slapped upside the face
every month is a new sleeping I'm like
damn like again I know they have the
data I've never really seen this type of
stuff I'm saying so again that's the
first part the second part you know
again with the modified precision
behavior total damage is unchanged but
non precision shots are significantly
more forgiving so again I'm assuming
based on this very you know not specific
jargon because we know that what is
significantly more forgiving me what is
that stat right this is typical Bungie
vagueness give us the hard number what
you know I mean so again you know I'm
not getting excited about this more
forgiving until I have a hard stat until
people put it through tests and see what
it is man so I'm hold on so revolve
oscillate we go shatter but I said it
has to be a boss in the next right yeah
hey thank you again we're shout to
revolver ocelot right shout-out to Forte
our ghost only boy this is again this is
gonna be my continued theñi this is them
testing whisper testing sleeper we'll
get into the next stuff later against
opulence content can't content yeah
that's what this is Solent six men like
whatever that six main thing is facts
all this that's all this is a shout out
the year at ease and maybe the new trade
everybody should ricochet shots off the
floor murder in the for that like what's
going on what's going on I'm done with
my rallied shoot jumping asleep cuz you
know me sleep late this hits hard bro uh
this is my favorite
gone I like this gun one of the few that
likes this gun more than gali this is my
baby and here we go again it's been
through a journey as well we had I mean
it was in destiny one it's this like
laser beam rifle you charge it up it's
kind of the first linear fusion I know
Crooked Fingers in there but it's its
kind of iconic it's been around it's got
the warmind feel to it I mean the bounce
was kind of cool but like the precision
damages Mather major
hitting those precision shots definitely
is good but you got to kind of be you
got to be powerful but I mean so many
things out class it now I mean yes
there's a lot of things that truly out
class it in many places there's just
there's a few places you can use it but
there's not a ton like I don't think it
needed it I mean now it sounds like the
reduced ricochet bounce damage on boss
combatants like I don't see it done a
lot but I don't think that's gonna
change a lot of people's behavior
modified precision behavior total damage
is unchanged but non-resident shots are
more forgiving so like total damage is
unchanged if you hit a precision shot
it's still the same thing am I reading
that correctly but non precision shots
are more forgiving I don't actually know
what that implies because mostly they're
talking about bounce yeah basically this
feels like a masseuse right so modify
the total damage is unchanged on the
precision behave precision shot behavior
but not so basically you're gonna get
good basically what they're saying is
use it like a fusion from distance like
a sniper
you'll get you're not we're not gonna
affect that damage but it's kind of
basically but the only versatility
sleeper had was that shoot at the ground
kind of stuff you know saying yeah chad
is hilarious which is home very nervous
your day Otakon showed is happy nerf but
oh yeah like a non-precision shots now I
guess the aim-assist is going to go up
but if you're gonna do that why can't we
get a increase to reserve ammunition oh
can I get a brick or something like you
doing all this every week like can I do
something but you know and last point I
make is that um again if we had to go by
ranking and I'm gonna throw this back at
you we both kind of agreed
maybe whisper was number one in as far
as heavy right in my opinion it's up
there yeah
right in my opinion sleeper when team
number two you can make the argument for
prospector you can later Lord you made
under London Lord literally when Thunder
Lord came out I was the first heavy that
made me stop using sleep because it was
multi-purpose right word cliff already
got slept war cliff got slack after he
just got buff my buddy got buffed I
remember that I remember that probably
boasted it was like a hundred and fifty
percent increase remember that ya know
and it was he so yep and then they they
go taking the fun back again it's just
this inconsistency but last point
sleeper this is unfair I can't I can't
but I'll let you rock out any final
words we're gonna do a little pour some
liquor for it for this leave me i'll
final words sips yeah so I mean that one
as you're saying just if you're gonna
take the ricochet if you're gonna take
again if you're gonna take something
unique about the weapon away don't just
strip it of something that makes it cool
change it and I think that's gonna be a
bigger discussion when we get farther on
with the rest of this stuff alright I
take the next one as well yes you know
I'm a lord so this one this one
definitely man uh Lord of wolves which
for the record he I just got this week
literally faded Ingram baby I was trying
to get all ballistic so I can kinda take
a screenshot just tease you if I was
gonna get it you know he was teased of
you because I didn't do a hurry but
anyway Lord of wolves here we go so
multiples received a massive increase in
damage with the full benefits of the
shotgun changes a season of The Drifter
this made it a lot more popular but we
got significant amount of feedback that
released the Wolves activating on every
kill made it difficult to control the
weapons ammo consumption as a result
we're allowing you to swap between the
two states to control the it output
while also reducing its output slightly
so number one
PvE damage reduced about 20% all right
sue release the Wolves perk has been
reworked oh that's that word you talked
about we were no longer triggers
automatically
kill this effect is now triggered by
holding reload similar to the
fundamentals on hard light in borealis
and then PvE damage and range bonuses on
this effect have been removed and
replaced with a universal damage bonus
instead okay
um I'm gonna let you start with this one
now tell you how I feel about this but
what based on do did you use lured walls
like especially in gambit or prime did
you use it at all he is he's gone Oh
mm-hmm
try not to type too much over you guys
I've seen what it can do and it can do a
lot yeah
but it's more like so the perks we're
talking about shrapnel launchers fires
it's a little burst so it's like a
little baby pulse rifle kind of it's a
little shotgun but it's got like five
ticks to it but release the Wolves
literally reads defeating an enemy
doubles the number of projectiles per
burst for a short period of time now
that's cool in theory but most of where
I see this used is just like everybody
get around a boss and pump damage you're
not defeating an enemy working on
releasing the Wolves you're just pumping
out a lot of damage so they're changed
to specifically say PDE damage reduced
by 20% they just think it's too still
too powerful
relief support has been no longer
triggers automatically on kill this
effect is now triggered by holding
reload similar to the fundamentals on
hard light so you change over to
basically doubles the number of
projectiles per burst okay on that part
PvE damage and range bonuses on this
effect have been a removed and that's
one piece is the range of resting and
replaced with a universal damage bonus
instead so are you just gonna like
switch over and dump through ammo fast
if you want to burn something I'm like I
don't even know how this is really gonna
feel until I get my hands on like I
switch okay I can give you a an educated
guess of how I think it's gonna fly like
I will say this and I'm gonna be fair
this is being fair when I had a lot of
wolves on console I know I pretty much
operate and to wait for it to get a
little PC I will say this when you get
released the wolves it is it is very
hard to control it gets a little
be right and you can fly through stuff
so I actually don't mind the tweak as
far as doing the borealis the HAR light
hole button reload to kind of control
that aspect and I'm Sam I'm cool with
that
damage introduction I don't know how I
feel about that because at the end of
the day this is another gun that blows
through ammo very fast here's the dinghy
correct me if I'm wrong chat you Lord of
wool owners I believe because it's exact
this is one of the few remember it's
kind of like a pulse II shot gun yeah
that shotgun reserve perks don't work on
it yeah I was like I don't know on that
one jacket I'm better ready pretty
certain but do you know let me know you
know check I'm pretty sure like I
remember having loadouts with you know
shotgun
what do you know if reserve vanish and
it didn't affect that ammo count unless
they've changed it I have not you know
seen it what's going on Chris covertly
good see brother um you know that that's
the thing that it's it really bothers me
so um you know this one I'm not I'll be
on not as mad I do like to tweak with
the UM the controlling the release the
Wolves but damage reduction there's a
little much and I don't see anything
which to me the real issue with the gun
is that it really it burns through ammo
yeah shout out the halo barrel yup
reserves has never worked with lord will
be incorrect the thing that's wrong with
it so it's just like again like the
theme preparing themselves something
this gun is in their testing in their
activities and oh boy
lot of those as well I got it now so
again taking some things that they're
like hey we're gonna take this weapon
that people got didn't really use bump
it up make it useful on some bosses and
things or close encounters you can burn
some damage that's too powerful again
and then now they're nothing again the
change is interesting for how the gun
actually it works again that's all just
have to see how it feels but I feel
that's not something I saw a lot because
where I saw it kind of come back into
or more somewhat in PvP a little bit
some people kind of like kind of love
and hate a little bit there but the boss
damage chunk like the only thing they
did is just make it weaker against
bosses in the pv aspect because the
automatic switch would not happen it's
not like I'm gonna go kill a random
enemy and then go fight Kali with it
people just like clean up enemies and
everybody get around Kali with a well
and just dump damage into her or I mean
however you want to work it but like
that was kind of its own thing so right
there yeah so we'll just have to see is
like I don't want to dive too much on a
general PC or focus on weapon weapon
absolutely so that's kind of Lord of
wolves Ace of Spades now shout out to
fall out cuz he's hit the nail on the
head of this first line perfectly
he said Ace of Spades is pretty hot in
crucible and he should have been
parentheses on PC and that is a hundred
percent true because ASA spades on PC is
like freaking everywhere I jumped into a
little bit of compound you can vouch for
that it feels crispy on PC feels damn
good but on console he was like it's not
there he's ps4 so it's not there so
you're hitting the smallest player base
with this one Ace of Spades is pretty
hot in crucible I'm gonna add on PC and
it has been in since its inclusion in
dusty 2 forsaken the number of perks on
the weapon combined with the
semi-permanent effective memento mori'
gives the weapon too many advantages
compared to other weapons now the
momentum or II ends when you stow the
weapon you'll need to make a decision on
whether or not you want to keep the
weapon drawn in to retain the bonus so
memento mori' now ends if the weapon is
stowed that's one the pvp damage bonus
of momentum Bora was slightly reduced to
prevent - tapping Guardians wild
vengeance one-eyed mask was active which
is probably fair it's just uh
specifically you need for resilience to
survive this which most people and maybe
people run with momentum or is active
for six shots now this one isn't quite
as tragic it sounds like it's probably
worse than it really is because they
took a little bit of the PvP damage down
but one-eyed mask really breaks a lot of
things anyway the momentum or e ending
when you stole I honestly was always
surprised that actually held
yeah me too I
to be able to be like hey I got momentum
Maury well let me stow these bullets
over here let me use my sniper rifle oh
if somebody gets close now I've got
these powerful things but and they but
they did that's one change they bumped
it up to six instead of five so it's
kind of like almost half your clip so
this one wasn't as much of a giant slap
in the face it's kind of like a wrist
slap a little bit to like take the
effect holding on forever and tweaking
the pvp damage this one isn't quite as
much so I don't think I'm crazy up in
arms about this one personally what
about you know I think me we share this
one this is one where I look this one is
fair I mean you know again as the data
plays so more comp I do see it much as
it's not as prominent on PC when I play
comp ace is running them streets
Hayes is one of the few guns that's
always you know besides outbreak crime
hey how you doing oh yeah yeah Oh long
as you know that's cool what all we'll
get there yeah we get there we'll get
there but um yeah like ace is the one I
do see anything cuz here's the thing
people people wouldn't travel if you're
upset about it you gotta understand this
though ace has that intrinsic radar so
you can stay down sight you know I mean
someone can stay down sight on a sight
line down the hallway and if that you
are named radar they got to memento
mori' Holden you know why you're stolen
that's a bit extra you know I know a lot
of you know guys running around with
that you know the one out mask listen I
don't feel this one's that bad
I think the weapon is still gonna be
effective you know I'm okay with this
I'm okay with this one fair enough
we got to see how I rock you know not
about I think me you wanna say in st.
Paul this one yeah some doubt one's not
quite as crazy so all right now we get
the armor I'm gonna roll all this and
we'll talk about the armor and then
we're gonna kind of go for an overall
exotic armor along with the weapons
above we also be making some changes to
exotic armor pieces primarily we're
paying attention to pieces of exotic
armor that grant back super energy we
felt that we felt they are increasingly
becoming must pick gear
gear choices or generation from
teammates is meant to be the best way to
accelerate your super generation these
exotics are allowing players to bypass
this teamwork mechanic by generating a
large amount of super energy without
relying on players orbs also because
these items are so overwhelmingly strong
in situations where players face-off
against large numbers of enemies some
activities were designed this is the
line I was talking about considering
down some activities were designed
considering the use of armors such as
Orpheus Riggs Phoenix protocol skull of
dire ahamkara etc this means if someone
your fireteam doesn't have these super
exotics equipped the activity becomes
far more difficult we are talking back
to that later
we're making some changes to these armor
pieces to try and preserve their power
fantasy question mark really and still
leave them as viable choices for
difficult activities without making
players feel like they must have them
equipped or be at a huge disadvantage
super generating exotic armor changes a
result as follows skull of dire Ankara
Orpheus Riggs and Phoenix Protocol
that's just a list and a half right
there now receive super energy back with
diminishing returns making it rare to
get back full super shards of gallon or
inertia furiosa had their super gain
caps reduced in part in variety with
other super exotic changes wise invest
had its energy reduction from 15 to 8%
for killing one to two Guardians scales
up for it similar to before when killing
through a more Guardians PvE energy
returns remain the same too before we're
sympathetic about the fact these changes
we make in the in in the interest of
balancing combat in game design can be
jarring understatement the century it
was important that we have this
conversation before you read the patch
notes we know many of you have a lot
riding on day one season opulence
hopefully this until will assist you in
building the perfect monster killing
machines for next season to play I will
give them that they get made it early so
those that are working for day one at
least can try and figure out what's next
because they have a couple weeks to be
like ok we got to flip everything on its
head
works the up front is good their choices
are a whole different question so exotic
armor your baby first skull man I mean
listen I'm gonna be controversial yeah I
I'm not upset at these nerves but I'm
upset at something else and what I mean
is that like the reality is you know how
much I love the reckoning right we've
talked about it last couple of last
words yeah and I go front you boy
running out to get soup is every five
seconds yeah your boy read it out the
boy shout out to my boy locks rested
peace fall out a little bit for that one
we had our run like put it this way
escalation protocol was a joke like I
would leave it is to the point I go for
it that is the only exotic I use when I
even smell boy but I even I'm gonna use
void today all right cool girl let's go
you don't say and it was a dope thing
not but here's the dip the problem I
have with this the stuff is that Jess
during their down phase II remember what
we were told
mmm-hmm go fast we want you to feel
powerful you we heard you remember
that's what they told us they were like
we heard you you're super tiles were too
slow you know you're not getting your
stuff back just and the dirt and now we
want to get you back to deep one baby
this is what it is right yeah did they
gave it to us and the community rejoice
well we are here baby we out here and um
it's just one of those things that is
just like okay someone I got shot they
do it on red who said it perfectly it's
like this is the whoa-oh-oh-oh
not too fast update pulling back on the
reins here like but easy buddy we don't
let y'all contradicting themselves so
many times and it's getting hard to
defend because you know again in the
issue of fairness II yes it is a little
out of hand I am getting supers back
everything I am I can solo strikes yes
go sit there act like a snob I gotta
give them that but again you just told
us you want to give us the power fantasy
right you know you just told us that so
it's gonna you don't be surprised when
people lash back at you right now
that's all I'm saying so I'm willing to
see what it do they saying diminishing
returns and you know it is what it is
but imma let you rockin I mean well out
of this list
what was your go tools like what was the
ones that you gonna hit you gonna look
now like to you know fax me so I'm a
Titan more often than not it feels like
lately so I watched a lot of this stuff
get used and I was always happy to have
it with me
yeah with somebody else but for me the
only one really on this list is Ursa and
I've only I've had rare Scituate like I
can go around on the reckoning I can
hold up my one like mobile shield wall
take a lot of shots and I don't always
get it back now when I was using it like
for example if there's a whole bunch of
stuff firing at you like a couple tanks
and a bunch of ads so zero hour for
example I used it when we were going
through that the first time and I was
just letting the two people behind me go
to town and I was just holding it up as
soon as it dropped a head it back but
that's me blocking like the world of
stuff like two tanks the boss like 10
ads like a bunch of stuffs firing I'm
like that seems probably about right if
it's gonna likely actually let me build
it up because I'm basically being a
mobile wall to save my other two who are
doing the damage the writing about
Earth's is like I don't do any damage
anything when I get it back I am playing
defense wall right now I try to support
true support role yeah like that's
actually a specific role Korea's
protocol now that one's different
because you can drop it and still work
mm-hmm
so but it was like it is one of those
where that person if they drop it and
suck they're not gonna give back they
have to get kills during that time so
they still have to put in some work so
some of these are like skulls just like
explode a bunch of guys get it back
explode a bunch of guys get it back
Orpheus Rick its head there hits a lot
of guys cool tether hits a lot of guys
cool tether tether tether like as you're
saying some of these are over-the-top
yeah yeah my issue and shout out to
those are both crazy wolf or the drifter
one that's a ton of fun to do why do we
play games what is our escapist that we
want to do why do we do this stuff why
do we take our time to play a video game
to get out there and feel powerful
Bungie already makes it hard enough to
feel powerful when I can go into patrol
and still get killed
I'm Louisville I don't even what level
am I now 700 and I can go walk out to
eat easy and if I don't pay attention
it's a little harder to get killed but I
can still get killed in a public event
mm-hmm if I'm not paying attention like
so when you take like always balancing
to some extent like to a cap level and
then you take our fun fantasy that you
gave us recently and shop us off at the
knees that hurts the other piece like
shout out to the drifter here's the
question people still are probably going
to use these for what they're capable of
doing because other exotics still don't
matter enough to be a choice hello which
asset I was like that's that's where I'm
going is and this was me back when we
started our podcast about a year ago
saying exotics need to feel exotic and
they need to feel powerful you need to
make like if I make a choice fine I'm
powerful in this way or this way or this
way like that's fine so if you're gonna
take these down a little bit because
they are over busted cool like I I hate
it shout out to ride for four months
thank you very much oh no run but if
you're gonna take away my my total fun
and fantasy right there with those
things in nerf it a little bit give me
other options take these other exotics
rework those which we've still been
waiting on forever give some of those
reasons to bump up and figure out why in
the hell like why are the why are there
three exotics that are so so this is
like the mentality of why are there
these three exotics that people use on
Titans and hunters because it lets us
feel powerful lets us have this power of
fantasy it's a ton of fun it's really
useful in certain places okay why are
these other ones not getting uses hello
look does they suck like some of them
really like some of them are just like I
even have many more because they're just
in my collections like I can go get an
exotic but okay and it's it's hard to
make all of them at the same level I
understand that mm-hmm but like take
each thing I mean I have this yeah I got
well I got one recently and just as an
example I got stronghold for the Titan
guarding with swords increases move
speed and does not drain ammo shots
blocked immediately after guard will
heal you like okay take a moment and
think about that's a brand new exotic
swords are in a crappy place you have to
guard all you do you guard and you don't
get ammo so it's literally one type and
these other exotics are helping like
supers in your power fantasy and this is
one now or weapon type and I don't lose
ammo when I guard like those don't even
feel like they and it's the only it's
not like I can use five exotics and pair
all this stuff together I get one choice
and this one choice with swords doesn't
have me drain ammo mmm-hmm how does that
even equate to the fact that if I'm a
hunter and I use tether I if I tether a
bunch enemies I can do that again help
make orbs for my team and slow down a
bunch of enemies on this tiny bridge
where I'm getting overrun by people if
blackouts the modifier I'm totally
screwed now let me go ahead and bring
out my sword and hold up defense like
those don't even a thats just one
example and there are many like that and
that on me go ahead no no i've been
talking for a minute go ahead use on a
role villages I'm saying like I'm just
gonna use the expression like a problem
with Bungie is bro keep the same energy
if you are so gung-ho about nerfing the
most you stuff and the most powerful
stuff when are we gonna see that energy
to all this stuff that's in our
collections exotics that no one's use it
like where is that energy and we've
always said this with exotic armor right
we've always said like there is tons of
exotic armor for each subclass that we
are not using right where is the bring
it up patch with yo where's the old is
underutilized so we I think we may have
gotten me early destiny too
with the you know the the the SunShot
graviton and those were getting he's a
weapon Nate he's a weapons right you
know I think it was briefly like they I
was a couple exotics way back I'm gonna
say early this is like during the
downtime right you remember we got some
exotic that guy a couple of tweaks and
we were like okay finally right but
think about every time we do it this
week is bungee right think about how
many times we talking about nerf in
something mm-hmm versus the time they
actually bring something that we know
what's there we get all excited right
like yo they bring up this exotic oh wow
you're not saying it's gonna be cool to
try like skull was one of them obviously
and stuff like that so it's just keep
the same energy man like I'm just sick
of every mob his nerve nerve nerve nerve
this this is too strong we felt this we
felt that but everything that's
neglected is not getting that level of
attention and again this opulence boy
hey liking what we doing right now huh
that's a you know eCos right now a prime
example the whole a on set Oh want to
talk about useless well exactly you have
three that like pair together or
something like that I mean those were
just like they came out went straight
into like dismantle I got so many of
those too I don't know they're drop
right was so high at a point in time
bags oh my god
so yeah there are a couple underutilized
the one like said Fred I'm saying Nezzer
X in with all void load out remember
that's F right there are some cool ones
but just it's like there it and I'm not
saying it's an easy thing to do it's not
but it is one of those pieces to where
it is really hard to balance things I
understand but if you keep plate putting
that glass ceiling and slowly smashing
it down on top of like the level of fun
the damage we can do and the power we
can feel at some point like you're
you're taking away the enjoy
of this space fantasy power craziness
what's the yeah so yeah I was like I
mean I know whenever they buff something
the whole community to happy Opie or not
it gives people reason to use that
exotic if they know now is there a point
where you do get to an issue of buffing
everything and then nothing is hard and
they do want to maintain that challenge
so that turns the whole conversation to
the next piece but before we do I want
to take a little break here just drop a
little ad here in the middle for you
guys so we're gonna take a couple
seconds I'll let that one play through
and we will be right back alright so the
main issue we are back that we're
talking about with all these exotic
changes and things that we've got going
on mostly is an issue of what is coming
yeah that's the thing and we gotta be in
fairness we don't know in fair this week
we need to see and um I'm just going to
tell you real quick before I forget this
point I'll break rhyme you have a
limited run brother cuz I see what
you're doing out here and I know what
did do it let you know what seems to be
consistent I was gonna say this last
point the I call it the thunderlord
treatment right what they do is they
introduced a gun great quest for the
most part does unless quest was there
but whisper treatment right great quest
communities galvanize y'all this is 1g
at its best
let us settle a little bit it did it's
like okay let's take that phone away
right whisper felt the raft thunderlord
member with thunderlord first drop II oh
my lord
thunder Lord was running them streets
right now it's outbreak primes time
you're a saint we see without break
there's no doubt in my mind this things
happening so I think what it is is that
the vibe I'm getting from this as they
giving us like a I call it a honeymoon
phase yeah I mean that's a diary damn
good way to describe it literally and
then they let us rock boom boom and then
take the rug rife about and I know it's
coming so it's just interesting to me
when it's gonna happen to me it's only a
matter of time
you know sampler let's get it to the
next play but this is gonna this is a
challenge but yeah it's like so we've
got
shoutout to Chevy he said I mean it was
just gonna quote his tweet here yeah and
there's just a couple of these like go
watch fall out plays on this
I feel like Bungie looks at that then
this is what I said kind of towards the
beginning at all the crazy challenges
that top tier players streamers
youtubers do and base the sandbox off
that we are a very small part of the
overall population and now you're not
only screwing with our fun slash
challenges but crippling others we will
find more weapons that they use we will
find the new best weapons for different
scenarios it always happens plus we
don't know it's coming in opulence yet
but come on late that's I mean verbatim
chat up Chevy very cool dude definitely
puts in some crazy crazy work on some of
his challenges and stuff but he is of
that level where he's gonna spend like a
day working on soloing argos with a
class figuring out things that's really
tiny people to do that stuff yeah so
you've got no it's gonna say and I
wanted to get back to your mention there
when it comes to out-brake perfected
because right now what you can do so
basically what I could do with I'm
trying to think what I tried it with
well I went against some for Jeff Turner
its VM so for death and shattered throne
and this is just with currently a Titan
so I did a rally barricade and as those
shots stacked up and actually had him in
a really crappy spot but as those shots
tacked up with you know the continued
little nanites adding onto the damage
getting up there I did about a third and
it's a primary and that's probably about
what I can do pretty close to like with
a machine gun as well and that's a lot
that's a powerful weapon now if you take
three people and now honestly as a solo
player as a warlock with like well as
anything lasts the whole time oh man
like I could I don't I could easily do
half if not more with a vac rhyme Airy
kinetic exotic now that feels fun it
feels fun that Quest is a pain in the
butt like even me so I have a whole
different ammo issue which is all things
that's pissing me off but yeah but that
gun is not easy to get its time
you got enemies and the front in the
back like you've got a crazy kill box of
a room between tanks and he's moving
around and all that stuff and the
jumping puzzles is legit like no joke
maze slash puzzle not just like a you
have to hit the jumps go in a straight
line you have to figure out where the
hell to go first like they made an
awesome thing and now everybody is
watching this going how long does it
last as you said because it's that
honeymoon analytics nerf maybe some more
analytics you may be a little up because
they over because they completely shot
it in the knee like they're gonna take
it too far and then they'll be like no
one uses this thing oh we're gonna bring
this thing back up a little bit but it's
still not gonna be what it was people
have moved on and there's the ring and
it's I don't I don't even I don't know
what all this I don't know what opulence
is gonna bring we don't know that for
sure right
we don't know I mean I also think it's
one of those things too and I think a
point that we also not looking at I
think someone did mention it in chests I
guess a libero and said maybe the new
raid exotic is not powerful enough that
exactly and I I am a firm believer of
that as well I think what happens is
they're about to introduce something
some new things and they want these
things to compete they want you know
this utopia of of weapon more weapon
usage because again this debt that's
based on that analytics everything with
them seems to be very focused on usage
rate by the community you know and
whether it's fair or not that's what
they do it you know I'm saying so you
know it's just it's frustrating because
we know it's going to happen we know
outbreak perfected is going to get this
so you know we will brace for it we'll
see what what's going on with opulence
I'm I'm so curious about this content
you have no idea man
like but think about this this is a
first I've never seen such I don't want
to say fear but like such dope we got a
control dish yeah before a content
release I can't remember this amount of
like these are like heavy hitting
weapons these are heavy hitting or like
they are going down the board right I
get it
normally don't we we get we we get maybe
one or two prior to a new dlc little dlc
release yeah whatever the biggest
outlier yeah legs and if it's not in the
middle
chop-chop-chop-chop back like just to
going down the road I've never seen it's
like they had a top ten list and they
put the top ten list it was like no or
list nope nope nope nope nope and I'm
just like man again optics right look at
the community reaction it is so negative
right now people like you are literally
taking away all my fun builds it's one
thing to get one or two weapons nerve
now you're talking four or five six
now you're talking four or five six
exotics like you're literally going back
on so much of the too fast update and
too powerful update you know I'm saying
so that that's where they really scare
me this part is just again it feels like
broad stroke you know I'm saying but
what what do you feel about that in
reference to before a big release like I
mean this feels like one of the biggest
leg sweeping changes we've had like
there I can't argue with that honestly
because yeah shout outs about the last
month we've had some discussions some
heated like my thoughts and stuff like
that and today we're just like brothers
in arms here but like holy crap what's
going on we got to work together it's
kind of like you know not in a my oh man
it's so yeah I mean opulence is gonna go
to 750 yeah but you know eCos also
saying there is a serious problem with
this so if you nerf he said is like nerf
to bounce designed for new content okay
so that's the new content but as
everything always seems the scales or at
least feel about at your level if you
take away these exotics and their
ability to manage something like the
bridge on tier 3 reckoning how the hell
are they gonna feel now you said you had
some like you said you've had some luck
with orangey like randoms I have not I
have straight-up had some insta
struggles like chatot for the blue bag
the open room alright fine you get to
the bridge and if you go if honestly
like tell me for people and this is like
this is a hard way to build I know
contents not easy to build and I will
always like defend developers because
they work their ass off but
like take for Streicher Titans into the
bridge no way in hell they survived
mm-hmm I doubt it you don't have any
defense you don't have any crowd control
you don't have anything like this and
it's just like oh mine so it's like if
you take four people to go in at the
same time and they don't check the other
thing you start the bridge you fail yep
so it's and I'm not saying somebody like
the elites probably can take four
strikers in there and do it but the
written the normal average group of
people who step into tier 3 and who
might be like hey this is the way at
least I know I can survive or there's
enough people out there that seem to do
this one thing maybe I can work on using
a tether and being beneficial to people
it's not even an option anymore so you
take the content they say that was the
line that bugged me almost the most
because they said also because you know
they designed some activities
considering this armor so if you're
gonna nerf the act the item are you
going to adjust the difficulties of the
activity accordingly or are you just
gonna make it next to impossible for a
lot of people yeah it's good it's a
really good point I mean we got to see
you know when it comes to meta I try to
be fair I really do you know I'm saying
and again to the letter of the law if I
want a full disclosure if I want to be
on it to the letter of the law these
don't seem as bad on paper it hurts to
hear about our favorites getting this
you know they say okay you're not gonna
get all the way you super back all the
way okay cool but when you make so many
changes at once it doesn't feel good it
doesn't it doesn't make it that's the
worst thing you want to make your
community feel as a whole when your your
message prior was something else and you
know we got to see we just got to see
man because of the community I haven't
seen him this upset in a while it just
came off outbreak perfected right it
just came off this like yalter oh yeah
yeah and it's just like you know I part
of me last point part of me think this
is like setup cuz it's like they knew
they was gonna do this oh yeah I mean
I've been thinking about it man well
let's get them now well I can't
she is good we could survive a little
bit of the blow but get creamed but then
we'll drop awfulness and they'll be back
again the other love us again part of me
think there's some strategic marketing
with a lot of this stuff but that's just
me baby I got my conspiracy hat on too
much more yeah timing might be a little
interesting on that one
but yeah I mean honestly we'll just have
to see what comes with opulence how
these actually feel welcome you're
either ace of spades it's not too bad
whisper is the one that's just like
whisper and sleeper sleeper I honestly
can't tell if it's actually as drastic
as it sounds mm-hmm and I know it's like
a change but like from what I read it
doesn't seem like yeah it doesn't seem
to like be as bad sleeper is a
straight-up nerf I mean not sleeper
whisper whisper is a straight-up slap
and that's one of the ones that was for
then is an outlier and the issue with
that is like if they ever worried about
that ever being a thing the quest is
cool but put another weapon at the end
of that quest
seriously don't bring it back because
you've been through it before and they
didn't learn their lesson yeah like they
they brought it in they're like oh it's
too powerful it makes all the bosses
easy let's nerd fit so it doesn't do
this hey we have amnesia we're gonna
bring it back with all the perks on how
it had original oh it's too powerful we
get it's like we've been down this road
before identically with the same weapon
and how that's that's probably the one
that hurts me the most yeah you're right
it is inexcusable for Whisperer to go
through this because we jet you you you
literally was scared to bring whispered
a desperate - destiny - right you scare
you're terrified to bring black spindle
right and you brought it back in this
specific way and you told us remember
they gave us the reasoning we made it
exotic we did this we did that this way
won't be out of control and here we go
again so I agree out of the list and I'm
asleep I whispered by far got it the
worst by far you know I'm saying so yeah
again it just optics man messaging all
of that counts you know and we got to
see openness better be later optimist
better be not gonna have to wait long
for the raid that's for sure that
in six hours I will be interested to see
like the strategy it feels like if you
got three characters save all your
normal bounties were like hey you've got
20 pounds to turn in fry quorum so start
saving as much as you can there four
different places
dreaming city you can go through there
and save up you know you can have like
the eight bounties saved so you
instantly get that one done you can
technically save like an ascendant
challenge or whatever you can save like
you can ascend a challenge I wouldn't do
but you can save the eight bounties to
turn that one in go do blind well go
visit morozov's throne go shatter
Thrones gonna be active which is weird
shout out to pyro cuz he was actually
saying it's like so they're closing both
raids mm-hmm yeah like when it launches
but shattered throne has just as many
drops as scourge and you good group can
burn through that probably just as fast
as a raid if not faster so there are
plate there's a lot of places to get
powerful gear that's was like 7:15
probably feels about right and
eventually we'll get up to 750 and maybe
2 or 3 isn't gonna feel easier maybe
they're testing this like maybe they're
like okay so at 750 tear through your
reckoning isn't quite as bad because the
Delta of damage coming in versus going
out you're gonna feel a little more
powerful you probably don't need your
super all the time it's like the crazy
horde mode won't seem quite as nuts
mm-hmm and it's just like a whole lot of
questions but as you said it's the feel
of what this does to and also it's the
fear of what it does for other weapons I
think is kind of the biggest issue is
like you've got Luna and not forgotten
they got there they're hit recently i
watch most people who do solo videos
because they get em oh I'm gonna be so
Bernal okay just a random side note here
my issue with ammo right now and I did a
lot of testing with the shadow - you got
me he's been in here before in chat
mm-hmm
I have an issue right now and like other
people don't which is a weird thing like
my account or something or I don't
understand what's going on I will go
through a social space right and lose my
heavy ammo like if I go hit a rally flag
I can go to another planet to a strike
to start like the reckoning like I can
go to the hall I can load into a raid
and my ammo can't count don't change at
all not one change at all so
everything's like cool so it's like I
want to go here
a flag and then go start up a solar
nightfall I'm good I don't have to pass
through a social space but if I go to
the tower or I go to the farm and
anybody who's listening this out there
tweet me hit me up in my youtube
comments something because I do want to
know if anyone else experiences this I
will go through a social space mm-hmm
and then I will go into anything else
after that go back to a planet go to the
farm and load up 0ur go to the tower and
load up a strike if I go through a
social space my heavy EMA loads as a
default so I'll go from like four
hundred bullets in delirium to a hundred
I'll go from thunderlord having to 40 to
75 I start those activities with my
heavy mo getting hit in the face but not
my special so shit's specific to that
hmm I wonder if it's a specific look
what what's your like I've changed
loadouts I've changed clothes I've
changed characters I've uninstalled and
reinstalled the game oh wow you really
would do
I'm trying right now look weird it was a
weird thing I took you got me with me
I'm the fireteam leader and at first he
was actually keeping his heavy but
losing his special ammo going through
the farm into zero hour which was
bizarre okay I got out of his party we
did it separately he kept everything I'm
still losing mine I've tried different
characters I've done different social
spaces I've gone to the farm to the
orbit to the farm like it doesn't matter
so if anyone else is experiencing that
please hit me up on Twitter hit me in
the comments let me know your experience
because I am very curious about that
because it's a weird thing that happened
started happening Wednesday after reset
because Tuesday I was fine still working
on you know my couple daily reset things
and then the morning I was doing before
I went to go take a class and then I
came back after what would have been
Wednesday's daily reset and it started
and I can't get it right no go ahead no
I would definitely a problem and I think
um I can't
I know eNOS okay I know he goes oh yeah
you know you made a good point have you
heavy finder protocell like question
yeah so inconsistent you know I'm saying
it's so in considering these are things
that you just there's no rhyme or reason
to how many bricks you get and stuff
like that you know
and that's why I invest heavily in
scavenging perks because just in case
I'm you see if I see it you know they
literally you don't say but um why my
vault is broken I'm scavenger for
everything yeah be to scale scavenger
Brown ask my joint that like literally
brought on yeah you you you probably had
a bunch of support and have yeah that
sounds very weird that's very strange
but that also like you know he goes
brings up another thing to like heavy
ammo and this is what kind of got me
into questions and looking more but
mmm-hmm they were met I like I didn't
see any mention about people have asked
to say is there a way to get a raid
banner spot in zero hour because the
like the role you go through say you're
like a group you're trying to do it's
like the normal mission especially but
either way even the heroic one because
there's a lot of attempts on this one
there's like multiple keycard tries like
all of those things
you still need a way to be able to work
through it we're not nerfing machine
guns at least let me get me the ammo
there but so the like the path you go
through right now if you want to start
it optimally take your fireteam to a
plane and hit a rally flag load into the
farm which is a social space and now due
to loading times in the way like their
system builds like a new instance of the
farm it takes me like a minute just to
just the load into the farm and then 25
people load in at the same time I've
seen that and it's just like oh okay
there's a new instance then you go in
and then you actually finally get to
start the mission if you fail and you
don't take yourself to orbit before your
time runs out like you're trying to do
it you have to go back to the farm then
load to a planet hit the rally flag load
back into the farm it's so like
time-consuming to play this new piece of
content yeah that's a bit much like a
debate I thought they would have learned
some type of lesson like white you put
it in a social space though they'd take
the heroic and they put it on the map if
you've played it once okay let me go see
it on the map too yeah it should be off
of that I think it's one of those things
with this trying in their defense a
little they're trying to utilize
underused spaces nobody's going mad to
fall that's what it is but it probably I
don't know if it's a server issue a
network issue it just couldn't hand
to that capacity now of everyone just
going there or something like that to
that effect and I think they just didn't
take into it it feels like they didn't
take into account that kind of effect
you know after last episode mm-hmm
that's what I guess yeah which oh I mean
been there you've got the perks of
course taking armaments fallen armaments
fallen absorption those types of things
to get the Grenada energy back or
following armaments to get those things
but if you don't rate or don't rate
enough or the people like you know
shadow to pyro who rated 60 times or
something before we got a thousand
voices what if you raid like 30 times
and you don't get that one mod yeah I'm
like that's your yeah and that's your
one way to get like better armor drops
that shouldn't feel right I mean the
whole taking away the orange bar enemies
drop in heavy yeah not all the time but
maybe every like two or three like to a
point they they have a whole heavy
weapon slot but they're always afraid
for us to use it yeah Wow with these
rights I mean they want heavies to feel
there but you build content that
requires us to use heavy to either run
it fast enough right or to be able to
like do the damage you need to like
outside of outbreak which feels like if
you work together and the nanites can
actually stack some damage you need the
heavies to be able to do I mean why do
people do scourge you're not gonna go
into scourge and be like alright
everybody pull out your I'm trying to
think of like a crappy example or
something like that pull out something
questionable well I don't even have
exotics that matter anymore like the
quality err everybody pull out your
two-tailed Fox no it's just kind of a
fun thing to use but it's like it's yeah
57 skirts clear sand still didn't get
energy like some of the drop rates and
things like that is kind of weird do you
let me ask you this question do you miss
the days of purchasing those heavy sins
hell yes I do
oh I would I would give like you know I
would give up I don't need primary sense
because I could never delete those oh my
god stop Nora all over the place yeah
but like I mean a five minute cooldown
or salt like or
it's just a scent that I can buy for
like shards and I can start my heavy mo
when I start a mission cool like takes
20 minutes like I'd be a cool down on it
like I mean something like that the raid
banners are cool for encounters that's
actually a really smart thing they added
in there but if it's something like a
nightfall strike or it's something so I
don't always have to ho go hit a rally
flag if it's like 20 minutes that's what
most encounters 15-20 minutes something
it's a long enough that you're like
you're not gonna abuse it but you can at
least start an encounter fresh and
things like that heavy ammo sense would
be a godsend right now I would be so
happy to see those back the og I
remembered oh that's a bum thing
shoutouts ooh a shackle shotgun on
Twitter just the the collection of all
the destiny news she watches Twitter she
watches reddit she puts it all together
which is cool and Cosmo saying hey it's
like they're taking the feedback like
ammo cents a raid banner in zero hour
like those things people want because it
is annoying to go out or go in it's like
the idea is like I'm either at the farm
or a man a ship and if I start a new
encounter why don't I just take a full
set of ammo with me in speed and
theoretically in lore like I'm going
through a social space that has like hey
I'm gonna swing by the armory and load
up my ammo clip say I'm in my ship I'm
gonna grab my ammo Clinton before I
start the next thing I should just start
each encounter full-on it like is that
hard like whatever your reserves are
just start full because I have though
they're not trying to hear it I'm
telling what I'm like but I can do it
with a writ rally flag I can do it every
time with a rally flag I can get full
ammo for a public event which is the
easiest thing in the world they're okay
with that I don't think they're okay
with it I think what they realize is
they in there again I'm putting you in
the mind of them Dave in their mind
they've made a mistake we're not
supposed to be giving them this so again
making artificial difficulty let's just
call it what it is yeah it's artificial
difficulty they're taking a space and
saying we want to simulate a struggle by
handicapping you of this power game you
know me and and then as you go along
maybe you get it the problem is that
that's really the problem is too much
probability there's no certain ways to
get it they take away they took away the
yellow bar automatically drop him they
took away the heavy scent they took away
all these things and again now I'm calm
little bit this is what happens when you
try to stretch little content you've got
you you create artificial difficulty
when you when they when they don't put
their all necessarily in the content
you're trying to stretch it you're
trying to hold your community off stop
community doing too much nurse Oh too
many supers stop oh it's literally like
all the things over cooking or not on
top of the oven and they sit there try
to shut it off that's what it feels like
to be and they gotta do a better job
that's why I cannot wait for opulence I
would because clearly they have things
in mind for us yeah but I mean yeah I
was like so a red banner can start each
encounter in a fight máximo every single
attempt you're maxed and that was a
fairly recent addition the r8 banner
started where did I start think of a
forsaken yeah I feel like last wish they
actually put that in a summation the
first time I ever seen it yeah so why
did you start a a fight in a raid which
is meant to be one of the hardest things
and I can't load into a strike the same
way because of strike and carry time
like if they did that recent enough that
that's an issue yeah I think you're like
in for your recent raid and forsaken is
something they added a raid banner there
is no reason I shouldn't like load onto
a story mission load into a strike load
into zero our mission just fillet mow
now mine's a glitch which is weird
but I still shouldn't have to go hit a
rally flag if my ammo directly just to
go load it again like that's the part
where I have on the issue is you set up
the hardest content to have a full
everybody gets a full run every time and
they've made that in there and then you
won't do it for other activities that's
like a bad consistency piece for me and
that's like that's one of those where
you're saying you know artificial
difficulty is because shut up by the way
on my mikey lights just freaking out so
if you see my like yeah he's like every
so often I'm like see if you're not
watching the video these are on YouTube
by there as well so shut out to the
YouTube channel yes so yeah on Twitch so
that's that's just a consistent thing
that bugs me the more I've like had this
ammo issue the more
been thinking about it which is just
digging me far and farther into this
hole of lake depression so it's just
like it's a weird struggle so yeah bro
you preaching not listen you know I'm
which I think you are completely right
just inconsistent it's inconsistent just
you can't have it in this particular
here is just come on and that's meant to
be the pinnacle of all activities like I
mean zero hours meant to be a hard
mission but rate is definitely like one
of the hardest things they ever build
the entire game and you get a red banner
every single encounter like yeah you
have jumping puzzles in between but
every single encounter hit the red
banner it's 5,000 glimmer they know
people have a buttload of glimmer it's
fine so hilarious so yeah at this point
like the whispers are gonna hurt like
that one's definitely gonna be but you
take the essence away but that one still
bugs me but yeah we just have to wait
and see they're gonna be talking season
of opulence is gonna be coming it's two
and a half weeks away man not that far
it's close not so yeah if you're
starting to work on prepping if you're
starting to save what bounties you can
try and get things in order try and have
your raid team ready now two and a half
weeks this is your time to start
planning to figure it out cuz it's a
six-hour run you don't have to take that
long off I don't know how long the raid
is gonna be my question is like if it
starts at 7:15 the way last was started
at 560 mmm ended up five no what was it
no it was like shadow throne for example
I know starts at 560 more for death was
580 deliveries 490 and that's 30 points
if you go 715 to like 747 45 those are
gonna be some tough encounters and you
are gonna be pretty squishy come that
final boss so yeah the grind is gonna be
interesting the strategy of how long do
you grind before you start are you
willing to let other people get ahead if
you're willing to get more levels or
people gonna be switching teammates is
it gonna be allowed I'm really curious
how that stuff goes so that'll be a
whole different discussion in a few
weeks there man it's gonna be a trusted
secret this is new territory
yep with that with the way to handling
rate so shut up by the way to Trevor who
has got a lot of
love and hate and scares and and all
those things lately that he has then I
have some had some people who have some
hilarious reactions out there so they
have some fun with those but they do
have a Trevor shirt so if you're a fan
of the crazy little rectangle robot who
crawls on those little crabby legs then
yeah they have a shirt out there for
that they have a couple of things there
I have not bought one pin yet but they
have a whisper of the worm pin I have to
get it better getting now I have to I
have to get it I haven't bought that
many pins some of them are cool and not
really like I'd have a good place to
store a lot of pins but where's your
wrist I love that special place because
shout out to everybody like that's like
one of those one of those things so it's
uh yeah it's been that one is gonna be
available to check out some shirts and
things they've updated their store a
little bit a little bit for dusting
player support they said there were
weird flash point timing that happened
everybody should be on the same page
there this is the last iron banner if
you're working on that crazy insane in
power to you right now that is a lot of
you on that
sirs final invitation of the nine is
that actually coming now I don't
remember if I did the I did the one I
think I did two back-to-back and I guess
this might be the final one so because I
know he had the weeks off but I think we
might be up if you are doing invitations
of nine and you like missed some it's
never gonna go away you will always be
able to always you'll just have to be in
consecutive weeks so it's fine that's me
and show it's outbreak by the way
breaking burgoo xia you cannot take it
into there on pc air every time really
bender and I both I worked with him on
it and it's literally walking in into
the gun it will break you every single
time can you do Burgos a solo with it no
I'm not trying to solo of a forge I'm
just saying if you take a weapon into
the forge just in general no I get you I
go like going by yourself yes I couldn't
even get near it
really Wow so just Eric crash out mm-hmm
Danis crazy yep
yeah gypsy a vendor super crashes yeah I
mentioned it before pretty sure that's
still there the final thing we're only
212 a from the start of season of
opulence we'll be sharing more on what
to expect over the next few weeks
it's been awesome watching players in
the community to take the time out to
help each others fight their way through
the zero and that is a really cool thing
like that is one of those pieces that
zero shows the art configuration and
shout out to GLAAD like with the ax like
him or not like his positivity his like
positive tweets on Twitter about the
community his love for the community and
stuff like that those shoutouts are
always really really amazing because it
shows what this community does really do
you've got people like saying hey this
number day door didn't work and all
these things like all this stuff to
build this ridiculous spreadsheet graph
like dial all to make those art can and
you have to do 49 entries in there I'm
like that is so a bit excessive yeah I
mean when you make a puzzle I understand
like and then people start figuring out
it makes sense but you sit there for
like 49 okay here 49 times I've watched
people solo it it's fine but 49 times
really what absolutely not that's a bit
excessive on the puzzle buns you might
want to pull it out to the community who
worked together to figure it out next
week's gonna be solar so that's one
thing as well
one quick aside before we kind of
wrapped up the Bungie talk for those of
you I did put a video out today with our
guards to chronicler it's the seal go
yes i retweeted it hmm so one of those
seals have there's two that are very
time limited pieces to it there's two
lore books if you are going for the
pinned that you can buy from Bungie I
know not everybody is but if you're
going for those those stop being
available to purchase on August 31st so
go check where you sit on like some of
them like you have plenty of time if
you're going through like let me get
through the six week rotation of
dreaming city and stuff like that there
are two that have very specific time
limitations in there its truth to power
and variks the loyal'
truth to power specifically if you are
not on like going tomorrow's throneworld
right number six this week while it's
there you can't get the pin Wow so it's
very tough so it's it not is like I'm
I'm gonna squeak in like my last you
I've got to be able to get it on the
27th four days before it goes off sale
so for those that are going for that
seal maybe you've been slacking and
you're going for the seal you've
probably been on top of it but if you
were thinking about it
check that one just so you guys know
just kind of where you stand at this
point
so that's one of the little pieces as
you know year or two is gonna start
wrapping up yeah got it like we look
yeah I much what's a real quickshot that
my dues you know Lunas Lunas nerf is
coming so get that still get a shout to
my boy Chris Monson get your service
revolvers it's in that same class 180 if
you haven't done it already grind those
strikes if you haven't done so they can
be added to the loop pole from Subala
once you know it joint pops off cuz that
it's kind of like Lunas light if you get
a good roll on it man so yeah shout out
to those people and I gotta finish my
stew yeah but that also makes me kind of
questioned when you look I was looking
at resets and like the last one is gonna
be August 27th to September 2nd
September 3rd is the reset we don't know
what's coming yes and that's like that's
literally I was like that I haven't just
going through and figuring out dates
September 3rd 2019 is the point where we
don't know what happens because that's
one opulence will stop and that's like
the opulence has got to answer a lot of
questions now after today because he got
nerfs and changes and what do they do
today's and how's the game gonna feel
and is it gonna be too hard or too
easier what the hell is gonna happen but
then the bigger question is what follows
they have a plan we know they do and we
don't know what it is but we'll find out
so no one knows so yeah definitely an
interesting 12 hours a lot can happen in
12 hours when you definitely blow up the
internet I woke up I saw you tweet I was
like is like the last birdies gonna be
interested I said oh boy yeah yeah III
is coming up in a few weeks we don't
know if they're gonna tease anything
there if they're gonna do their own
timing before a probably after cuz I
think literally you're gonna have like
season launches raid III the next week
like all that's gonna probably encompass
that first week and then we'll probably
get a calendar but yeah somewhere in
there we're gonna learn but I don't
imagine they're gonna let III like swamp
them too much you
and then we figure out what's next but I
got a feeling they gotta say something
because a season of opulence they they
all tend to be a little front-loaded
like with what we get like the for just
starting K you've seen the Fords okay
you get a couple more okay here's the
reckoning and it came to prime and you
know like you know you'll get a couple
different levels we're gonna get the
raid the six-person matchmaking thing is
probably gonna come like late June early
July my that's kind of my assumption
guess is when we're probably gonna start
hearing something as to what comes next
because they can't wait for like too
long they can't go another be like they
can't be two weeks before like they've
been with the annual pass because we
know we're still in the annual pass they
can't wait that long for people to be
like hey I wonder what the fall holds so
my assumption like July first Guardian
comes right there I don't know if they
would quite drop it there that would be
a feel early yeah so I assume there's
gonna be some stream or something
they'll do and they'll control a message
but that's kind of the timing my guess
for that so we will definitely see but
shout out to another game more other
game because at this point this is the
two game podcast for the time being the
Iron Man simulator will be on the back
burner for a little while so that's just
gonna yeah yep no this yeah like they
gotta go do their like blue 2.0 thing so
division to drop the rape interesting so
it went live for me at 11 I was trying
to literally drive home and watch I was
literally like glancing at my phone on
Twitch watching people like work it as
it was light live they from what I saw
what you saw what you saw talk tell me
give me a feel give me you feel the raid
of the division tracked like so before
the raid even dropped they dropped a
bomb on a lot of people yeah and let's
talk about that so there's one piece
when it comes to your messaging to a
community sometimes Bungie may like drop
bombs like this and expectations may be
a little weird but they've never like
plastered anything on an advert
before that said hey this will always be
their matchmaking they said and they
have an infographic of it matchmaking
will be in every activity at all
difficulty levels it flat says it how do
you know about that little infographic
is out there I've seen it many of times
it trust me if you google it it people
pulled that thing back up really fast
yep
now this brings up two different things
if you watch this raid randoms would
have failed just like in destiny where
there's a reason they don't do it like
Bungie is held to their guns and said
we're not put wool like they'll do the
guided games of like five people who can
train another but if you go matchmaking
in a raid like people can get up in arms
about it because the like the marketing
said hey it's gonna be there and they
expected it and they only gave you like
literally 24 or 48 hours to say time to
find your fireteam on the internet or
what they got a gate like - it's hard
enough to find six random people now if
you get a fireteam of four but you play
with a group you're like maybe we'll
pair up with another four you gotta go
find them first
you gotta be in that actual paired up
matchmaking Scituate everything in that
game has matchmaking except that so that
was like a crazy thing but if you watch
this raid you would not want to
matchmake into it I'm gonna say that
right now because they put some cool
mechanic now I didn't see every
encounter I missed a couple catching
different streams some people farther
ahead or certain things but from what I
saw you cannot do this it is a it is a
straight-up read you cannot do this
without communication talking certain
people filling different roles different
loadouts coming into it no way in hell a
random team would be able to do that you
have got to communicate and they they
made what I saw for a first raid for
division in the world of based of like
realistic Washington DC they did it cool
job I'm honest I'm like I'm watching the
encounters like the first fight so
spoiler
warning if you don't want to see it or
you're gonna go play it fine because I'm
doing this from watching people on
Twitch so there are ads around installed
Oh believe me I'm sure you'll correct me
but the general idea is you have one
main boss tune in this like kind of
first encounter which was what held up a
lot of people for a while that I was
watching he's got this like chest piece
that they have to shoot it pulls aggro
to him if it's green it causes him to
heal so you gotta keep that thing
managed the entire time they're like
mini guns on a couple sides of the room
that you would have to pull him to but
then turn him around so they could shoot
the mini and I was watching 55 do that
for a little while she'd be on the
minigun they'd like whoever would add
would run towards the minigun so he's
over there like kite him over turn him
around and then she'd throw the minigun
on his back break him get him to kneel
then you could put some damage into him
he'd stand up you still get this giant
thing and if you're near him you're
gonna get squished
and then they'll stand up you got to
make sure you manage the chest plate for
his healing but there's ads going around
there's different pieces that like stop
they he'll I'm like I'm watching the
first encounter like damn like they they
made it an encounter and like from what
I saw like the communication was real
the damage exagear score was up there
the mechanics or I honestly like just
watching that first encounter from
multiple different people watch him
figure it out it had a cool feel to it
solutely boxes for coming all the way
around there I had so much read slander
from about being a taken salute I mean
no that was led to you that was the
vision wise incursion yes your planned
about this time listen I got a gig music
I'm just dancing back a profit I'm proud
of you may cuz listen you know listen
you know I'm with you I mean I came into
this thing very low very low I said one
there's a lot of things in my opinion
again when we had this discussion as
destiny guys we have rigs in this upper
tier and there's iconic moments I have
to understand this is a different game a
different setting realistic world and
eight players so I'm sitting there like
no we got a C right and the thing that
literally made me smile was people
communicating was people saying hey wait
a minute
do this you go here I shoot this you
know I'm saying or I spin him like I
shout out the Marco style I was watching
what it is you know and they got to what
I think is like the UM the last
encounter
maybe once credit for this rate I don't
know why but he must be talking he hey
he was a lot of credit for turning
people around but anyway but um yeah
like at the end of the day it was just
like cool to see that in division
because I give you this eat like
everyone's greatest fear was what you
said right initially which is we gonna
be in a small room maybe like the first
and everything everybody should take it
we gonna be let you know so to see that
and this to see mechanics in division
good job boys good you know I gotta be
honest me being the destiny purist that
I am I have to point out some little
nitpicks that they could improve upon
for the next one
let's hear all right so shout out to get
Lord at it cuz you know he's already guy
and go ahead he made some points and um
here's the day I feel that as for their
first attempt solid solid boys they
worked on day one for the most part you
got incomes you got mechanics but here's
where they got a dig deeper into the
destiny bag if you're doing a raid right
you need to face enemies in my opinion
that you've not seen like enemies that
are very unique or have unique mechanics
prior to the outside game I didn't see
too much of that and I'm saying so I
would like to see that and then also
with the boss encounters I kind of want
to see more epic I shot the PDE at this
discussion offline I want to see boss
encounters that give you fear that's
like you know something hunting you down
it can wipe three people at one time you
know I'm saying like again not saying
that nothing in their raids had any type
of white mechanics that could hurt you
I'm not saying that
but you know one thing about a destiny
rate is it's something to be said you
know when when some single entity is on
you like oh my god out of here you look
like like it's something to be said
about that you know say and again I
understand a different game realistic
setting but I still think there's things
they can do and as far as the last boss
thing again I saw it seemed like I said
it had great mechanics I just wanted
something if they have to get the
essence of an epic boss fight down in my
opinion dps is cool but you got you need
epic and I think they can do it do I
actually have confidence that they can
do it because this is gonna be the first
raid a clearly gonna have rate Horrell
good I've said before the first one solo
you know I'm saying we just got I just
want those more that's just me the
destiny raid perfectionist that I am cuz
I know they could even do not cut out
the part even more the next time but
that's all I got yeah so I mean that and
that's kind of a fair point like I
didn't dig I didn't catch everything I
didn't see every single linking counter
fight understand every mechanics not
like a go go do it right now but from
what I did see like the main boss that
seemed cool I saw one where you had two
two of the mechanical dogs
yeah and had to keep the health close
like that was kind of a unique way to
handle multiple enemies if they've kind
of done stuff like that before in
destiny where it's like if one pisses
off the other one type thing like so I
mean that was actually kind of cool the
little bar was actually pretty obvious
as it moved and what happened if they
got out of their ranges and stuff like
that so I will say from what I saw
though if you and it's one of those
things in division that I think - their
dependency on cover is so important yeah
you're feeling of squishiness is I mean
I know you're one dude and I know it's
kind of realistic but like you people
just would be like I'm gonna dropped
like there's not like an over shield or
this level of like hey if you do it's
like if you get hit by like one of the
wrong guy
you're toast right and it's it's very
unforgiving that I gotta talk about the
elephant wanna shut up
Tasi I don't know if he saw his latest
article this morning
haven't you all right here's the deal
apparently only PC has beaten the raid
oh no one on console has beaten great so
we know they have a unique approach
where it's not like destiny where you
got a kind of power level you get there
but C potassium makes a great point and
what he's saying is it's very it's just
different I'm not gonna say it's wrong
I'm just gonna say it's different in the
sense that destiny players would used to
yell we got to be a dis light level you
know I guess their equivalent of gear
score and then we'd be able to tackle
certain challenges with them it's like
yo you have to have this kind of bill to
do damage against elites and you got to
have this kind of bit if you don't have
those kind of bills even if your gear
score is whatever you are not getting
past encounters so that is a huge deal
I'll try to send you that link so you
can see it but yeah he has a good point
about that and I'm curious about how
moving forward they handle this because
as only PC has beaten the r8 like no one
on console you know I mean has got net
wells frustrate that to me very
interesting obviously know the frame
rates a little lower and there's other
issues of stuff like that but I thought
that was very surprising yeah I mean the
struggle is real what I saw like what's
a lot of people still be sitting on that
first or a second encounter after mm-hmm
you know 10 12 hours it's not like
there's four or five so I don't know how
many there are if there's like four
encounters maybe I'm not sure I can
think of at least three 100% you've got
mouse and keyboard so you're like aiming
is typically for a lot of people is
gonna be easier so people prefer
controller which you can still use but
you have your frame areas potentially
like four bosses okay it was right but
yeah you got a console like you got the
thumb sticks you're trying to do these
precision shots you
like a minigun and they got to turn
around and run and like turn the camera
around and stuff and there are certain
things like man it I can see where I
wonder if they've stepped it a little I
mean they they made it difficult that's
gonna be the question but if like three
teams that's it on PC have done it and I
know I was watching more than three
different streams and no one on console
mmhmm yeah absolutely it's it's some of
that is I guess the point of and it's
when you even play like you are so
squishy out of cover yeah and when you
make a big open encounter where it's
like hey I can kneel behind this thing
then I've got like four drones the spawn
in front of me and then over here and
there's one sniper I don't see that
screws me mm cuz I don't have an over
shield or anything and then if you look
at the wrong thing it's some of that is
there's big dependency on covers so much
it's one of those pieces for encounters
that I watch like most people manage it
but a lot of that they wanted you to be
mobile yes
and it's hard to be mobile in that game
in it in the same way it is like you
can't like jump around or float or it's
not does it have the mobility of destiny
so when you're running around and like
hey these missiles are gonna hit the
ground where you're just holding this
thing down for a minute I've got to run
around well there's three ads that are
shooting me now I'm like and I'm not yet
and the game's not built for that so
right I'm pretty geared and tanky with
my true patrol setting you got destroyed
so I mean that's not oh said so it's
like it's one of those that's I will be
curious how that thing paces I like I
like the structure I like the structure
I like the mechanics I liked how they
you know kind of made the communication
a crucial thing and that's why
matchmaking is not there yeah that's a
big thing but also as you said I mean
when it comes to raids coming from
destiny coming from World of Warcraft
you I mean the first account is an
armored dude yeah yeah that's what I
mean then you have to mechanical dogs
we've seen those in d2 they've been
running around with them so it's like
the enemies that you fight need to have
that feel that's what you were saying
before and that's that I will hunter
could agree did you imagine even if it
was just um I won't say like a noose
in but just a new animation somebody
with a new type of sue something that
seemed wrote Boston you buses through
the door like y'all I've never seen you
know captain whatever your whatever
their generic babies yes but you like yo
we gonna have to team up for him you
know I'm saying the disc this guy it
he's doing different things that's the
only little nitpick I got because to me
that adds the epicness he again division
guys so no that's what you got to learn
from destiny destiny has that yo did you
see golgoroth your this no
did you see you and I'm saying like the
epicness again I'm it can't be space
magic II we get that it can't be no
fantasy and monster I get that well you
can give us another type of soldier you
can give us another type of dog or
another type of enemy type that's only
in that rate so you go yo again if just
I am nitpicking right now make no
mistake I was very happy of this I
thought it was solid I thought this is a
great foundation and I'm pretty
confident that they will take feedback
you know next go-around and I wonder
about the mass making last point I'll
say about that is your destiny now no no
that's making baby your destiny now so
you learn you learn that's a good one
cuz the community's mad at you but stay
true because at the end of the day you
need communication you don't want to run
around with a whole bunch of blueberries
randoms in there it forget it'll be a
mess especially mmm-hmm yeah it's like
the more people like coming from Wow and
shout out to a smelled oh it's like when
you come from wow you had forty people
doing things yes the more people we have
the roles are even more specific and
it's just gonna be and said a couple of
the fights are very much based off while
fights and I mean if you're gonna go
learn if you're gonna try and at least
implement raids into a game based on a
game Wow is the best I mean they did
some of the most epic stuff of all time
destiny has done amazing things too but
when you manage 40 people and still make
them talk yeah that's a hell of a feat
so I was like if they're gonna learn
from anybody they definitely looked at
the right source because that craps
awesome so but yeah it's like from when
you see in the trailers there's like the
big floating helicopter like there's no
that's what I honestly thought is it's
an airport
is gonna be some type of aerial field
missing facts that was gonna be either
you know get the helicopter get it to
where it like you do enough damage or
something like that to this thing it has
to land and then something gets out like
a two-phase bossfight something like
that's the unique you can stay in that
military field now I mean it'd be kind
of hard to have a helicopter crash which
would be no animation but then like the
guy gets out shakes off all the rubble
or something and then he's an axe gives
that something unique to it as opposed
to this armored dude to dogs armor dude
yeah see all the last one I know the
last one has like it's like looks like
kind of a mini little missile silo you
shoot the little yes shoot the loop a
grenade and shoot those shoot those like
there were certain markets they had to
shoot which was actually kind of cool in
specific but I don't know what happened
after that if there's like a guy that
pops out somewhere if that's literally
the damage you do to the boss like
that's it is weird right
oh could you imagine like this like even
like you know maybe stopping the enemies
um from like launching some rocket or
like stopping like for example could you
imagine like a plane or f-16 that coming
down swooping through making the run f16
phase y'all get out the way you hide
behind it you don't say like if somebody
feels yeah like there's a point where I
mean there are very like very
telegraphed mechanics in any game for a
boss fight this is a very telegraph like
hey it's like it's lining up like
somebody does a lays and what does it
say the boss like laser tags an area in
between to him in this area is where
like the bombing run will go and
everybody's got to move outside of it
something like like those are things
they can do later and kind of a cool
thing about it but that would be that
would be your way to take away from
shooting the armored dude I mean the
mechanics moving the guy are just the
first encounter that I watched more
in-depth than anything else I mean it
had definitely that raid field the
communication the teams working together
you guys have to manage ads I'm built
for more elite damage so I'm gonna work
on these guys over here so I kill the
ads I'm probably maybe squish here but
the minigun works for me cuz that's my
build more I've got the raid heels like
you've got teams and roles and stuff and
cools like that but yeah it's like you
want that uniqueness of like eaching I
mean still one of the best is taking
king of Oryx comes out from underneath
your giant
Foreman is like the size of a small ship
and you're like like some of the best
like little gifts are like seeing Trevor
for the first time as people see an
aurochs like holy those moments earn and
in here you later okay what do I do with
this armored guy like that doesn't give
it's it is still based in reality and
it's hard to get to some of the sci-fi
but like what if the little things you
had to shoot was like that somebody like
drives through the airport wall in a
tank I mean you've got to hit like okay
sir first we got to hit the treads okay
you do that then the gun goes and like
he changes weapons he uses and things
like there you destroy the tank and he
comes out different you know some just
you can get bombastic still in that city
I agree I think that's a great analogy
with the tank and no bombing runs a
plane and you can still do epic things
and I think the potential is there this
is a good first start you know again us
guys that's good guys okay that was cute
yeah but shout out to them though for a
solid first attempt with tremendous
stuff to build on in the future but yeah
honestly I wanted to say hats off to
those guys I know the raid got delayed
but they did come out with a great first
swing because they haven't built
something like that before I mean
granted you know they hired on people
have you done raid encounters before
anything whatever game it's from to
understand those type of mechanics cool
they probably had to build a whole team
for it just the way Bungie has their
raid in-game team and that's all a whole
different building situation in itself
and they they made the challenges of a
raid what it needed to have and I think
honestly they stepped out well took a
little while to get here
the magic weapon like the matchmaking
was kind of a big slap before it started
and I'll be kind of curious to see this
and this will be kind of the point of
contention to test as like does the
positivity of how it sounds or is the
difficulty to hard right what it does
for people who may have like burned
through the content got to world - your
5 and then chilled for the last month's
may be playing something other are they
like do I need to between it direct you
out like it is it gonna be that thing
that pulls people back
right and then we got to also break that
I've got a chance to see we got a
breakdown rewards because that's also a
big part of rating right
all these rewards that they're giving
you know if I know smile those still in
chat maybe you'll let us know are these
rewards these gear sets really cool and
diamond so people I gotta get in it cuz
look at what these guys got cuz that's
another thing that's the thing destiny
has that care you go you like y'all you
got what what gun is that you know or
hey what suit is that what like you need
that aspect you know I'm saying so like
I said III I still think you know you
get a solid B from me for a first time
you know impressive man impressive
oh the gear sets a tie every better yet
so would sing old oh what you're gonna
tell me you get data thank you exotic
assault rifle does everyone get that
completion is that a random drop for one
of the eight do tell they still have not
had renewed specialization so what well
the specializations I thought came with
each Lake season I'm gonna call those I
thought were gonna be added the three
new ones I thought there were three
armor sets that I saw on the raid
graphic and then the exotic assault
rifle but so it's a random so they're
basically 1000 voicing they're also yeah
yeah huh interest yeah I mean that's one
of the big things about content is the
reward has to be there and that's kind
of the same piece with destiny sometimes
is like is your gambit prime armor worth
grinding out reckoning to go and again
but premon only use it in the little
bubble same thing yeah I got a problem
with this because you asking eight
people to do this right they should at
least have guaranteed drops for some
gear set and then a chance for one you
can't afford one trade without the
rewards I'm sorry
shifting conversation I had to deduct
points then snow comes in with a mic
drop in the last possible five minutes
and opens a new door I don't you eight
dues if only one got a chance it is
exotic assault rifle and nobody getting
anything else and it's like yeah guys we
did it after all of that
oh btw I don't know man
oh no I bye we got a dreary review
[Laughter]
that's like running last wish and all
you get is 1000 hope one person and that
one person like yeah and every person
every once I was in a rage looking at
they get nothing else no exotic armor no
are you saying I get level 500 gear but
that stuff you can get from the world
right now you're not getting the 515 the
higher T like you're not okay I know the
podcast is gonna sound we are weird
right now everybody cuz shout out to
Snell DOE and Lords about net he's uh
he's in the mix right now because we're
a little removed from this one just
because of life and other things yeah I
mean level five hundred years four ish
is where most people were before this
thing launched if you're getting
vagabond Dozo fire did you write the
twelve this week he says mom's left and
right bro this is not a good look daddy
thanks brother yeah that's exactly what
it is like I got the rocket launcher
from the raid that's all yeah the salt
from your other teammates if you get
this exotic and and they just get a
thank you guys yo that's all yeah if
we're reading that rights now though
like correct me if I'm wrong I know
you're saying you get 500 level gear but
also confirm that that's the same stuff
that drops did you get cool apparel in a
patch okay yeah the - no no no it's
dropping hard faster yes drop is so one
of the things about tough encounters cuz
this podcast just got longer um is what
you get for doing it so she also says
okay so the normal stuff you get so
world to your five that's a you'll work
your way up to gear score 500 but
running your missions and dailies and
things like
that it's like going into so it yeah
take its like bungee and going into and
getting you know blues and and not even
raid legendaries it's like getting you
know five edge transits for doing last
wish road this is so bad like date
delayed this raid mad times you should
not have launched it without that I'm
sorry no yes this was not ready I didn't
notice I appreciate your honesty this is
no this is this is your AMC territory
they cannot drop a raid with the gear
for the raid is not e I'm not doing it
I've said he he just mean me and attic
was like we gonna power novel this
weekend we don't get this rain you're
like no rush no rush until that stuff
say my hombre prime this weekend thank
you no no no no we're just like sitting
here just daddy I'm like what what we
saw such a high praise for this realize
Jodi did it it did yeah job to rush out
the people being real you get a bit
phony
yeah so lesson learned which shouldn't
have been a lesson honestly if you
delayed it already and then they like
magic it's coming in two days why the
hell would you do that after like if
your rewards for your activities that's
why you do these things these crazy
crazy eight person communication hard as
hell bang your head against the wall for
hours and you don't have the actual
advertised pieces of whatever supposed
to be in there like this is how you
become more powerful these are these
special perks it's not there oh man oh
that ease how many last words we've done
but we say yo rating the raise delayed
again I would say at least 5 - or that
to be delayed yeah yeah yeah we've said
this week they didn't get it right
they're gonna balance they're doing it
way we gave them so much rope what is
real like yo like Forte I need help yeah
I needed to pro how I get down with your
net cuz I don't know if I'm power level
or this red today give me I need yes I
be don't give me a patch give me give me
some gift since I want some fly stuff I
was some air power some TSA gear it was
TSA exotics yeah I was like they delayed
it the game launched March 15th if they
were wondering when they were gonna
launch it for people to burn through it
about a month would have felt about
right they delayed it another month and
the gear sets are not in there that is
they had to a how how do you how do you
do that that's awful that's poor
planning a dad it makes no sense
anybody want to consistent ly run this
raid like why but just massive massive
massive in that hand slap right now no
this is TSA give me something bro make
don't give me a pat don't get me no am
could you imagine doing a raid
everybody's getting emblem that's it
yeah you guys you got your emblem in
your shader
all right go have fun enjoy it can any
Pete last question and we move on okay
you what it has anyone tested the exotic
that um is dropped out is that as anyone
Tessa's like the god mode I hope it
really like yo this is the exotic
assault rifle or whatever it is that
this one person is getting out of eight
yes yeah please give us that one will
will the fun yo did you have to say most
rewarding publicly than ever to blue Oh
took a hard turn the exotic throw is
godly I mean and that's fair if it's one
gun now and that would be one of those
like a you know hey I get raid gear hey
we get raid weapons but this one crazy
exotic is hard to get you're gonna have
to run it a lot that mate I mean that's
okay if that's how that drops cuz that's
how a lot of those work if you have like
your inr key you're at thousand voices
your vex mythoclast like those are
specifically that way for like a chance
on that final encounter yeah you got to
make a raid but you're building up other
stuff as you go mmm and other bosses
yeah and other how about this for bosses
and the other three ain't given that
need think about it we'd even talk about
that each encounter should give you
something unique hello or at least like
this is Laura or it's gonna be like an
armor set in a weapon drop like of
certain things from that raid like that
raid should have its own loot pool just
as like the raids do so like you should
have maybe your armor sets like hey but
you and you've got three different armor
sets or whatever so maybe it's like okay
so like the helmet the I don't even know
what the pieces are say the boots and
your chess piece or whatever drop from
the first one each boss gives you gear
but does it give you the new gear it
doesn't give you the Cure sets and
that's the piece like each boss you know
they have to have the armor sets so it
gives you normal gear but it doesn't
give you the armor set so like you might
get some and honestly what it should do
is like if it's gonna drop 500 it should
be dropping 515 normal gear also a champ
like maybe one gear set draw a like one
piece out of three gear sets for
different builds and random roles like
you're gonna have enough randomness in
the first place a normal roll at 550 you
know if they're doing the gear score
maybe it's just 500 then maybe like the
gear set roll a chance of you know a
couple different weapons from like the
whole raid could be random that's the
emblem right
they should have held this another week
well I mean that's mm that's excuse yeah
I mean yeah if you're getting something
from it that's one thing but like the
thing you advertised to come from it
aren't in there great why you've waited
this long why force it like why have it
come and be like hey this is really hard
nobody on consoles beating it and you
get nothing like you want to talk about
like shooting like what good faith you
built with the way the encounters were
made quickly it's gonna be a way to do
it yeah grace oh yeah hard turn hard
hard left hard left
yeah I guess we'll see what happens over
the course of the next week should be
interesting the Internet's reaction and
videos and I'm waiting for dados
reaction video to this one cuz they'll
be like thoughts on this topic go go
fallout had his out last night and I was
just like he's the first line was good
and then I didn't even get to the rest
of it cuz yeah so I think that's guys
where we will wrap this thing up for the
day honestly chat today you guys have
been amazing I do want to shout out just
to check on a couple things from this
morning so new followers so we've got
dredgen Lord Thank You bender for the
resub drifter for the Risa Mirai for the
reefs of all you guys I've got Anubis
CNET OB art Rd Chris m3 and Hill Tech
for the follows and Caillou Tim for the
$10 donation as well so you guys have
been awesome this morning so thank you
that's all it was gonna be a crazy day
to talk and you guys made it even better
so absolutely thank you guys for being
here so if you guys are listening to
this thing on audio it is out there on
all audio platforms
shout out to anchor FM as well and this
is like not even an ad this is just me
like if you ever thinking about doing a
podcast anchored on FM you upload it it
goes what like they work on popular they
are your RSS feed they send it out to
all Spotify Apple iTunes all that stuff
and then they'll handle on budgets
it's so easy to use so that's my piece
just from personal experience of getting
the audio out we got over 100 listens on
the last one so shout out to all you
guys that are catch you no audio I'm
taking it wasting your so and I think we
just got another follow with a holes
Patrick so thank you for that as well
wait wait that be cold no no the holes
wh OLS nobody knows we can do a whole
lot right now yeah he went off to go be
a shout out to everybody thank you guys
this morning if you want to rap we'll
wrap this thing up I'll let you go first
through where they can find him what you
got coming
yeah man you already know Lord [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah at Lord carnita on Twitter and of
course the Isle of podcast YouTube
channel and Lords of gaming dotnet I got
an article up on the table on the nerves
if you missed it you missed you're late
you just want to get up to speed on what
we were rambling about as well you know
check that out as well and now this
Sunday big big show man check us out
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern on a podcast
YouTube channel we are bringing back our
prediction series so it's gonna be
all-star panel we can we talk about
Nintendo in the building see so hot the
cops come yo check this out man yo it's
gonna be a all-star panel we're gonna
have our man we're gonna have stealth
40k which is our market data researcher
that's a lot for you as far as in
Nintendo in that space we shall have my
boy mr. negative from your panelists or
it kind of funny so that'll be late
you're also we got my boy potentially
perfect great Nintendo sub and of course
saving the very best shouldn't say best
for one of our very favorites for last
Eric's gaming returns oh good we're
gonna be having some fun we got like a
lot of people on that one man you got a
loaded there you go there you go get the
Chavez get the haunt is gonna be late I
love pockets Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
we're gonna total and we also we got to
talk about the major deal that also
happened in
between Sony and Microsoft even though
it's a Nintendo show but we gotta talk
about so check us out on a podcast
that's what I got pre-dawn Joker with
just the recent follow as well thank you
yeah no it's been awesome you guys know
where to find me it's Yvonne tests
everywhere somebody was asking me the
other day where my name came from some
day I mean tell that story to this group
but it's easy to find EB oh and T is
Twitter twitch YouTube follow sub like
all the good things you guys know where
to find me now it's your time if you're
working on grind up things out you guys
know what's gonna change so put your
time in if you're working for seals if
you're working for you know wish end or
whatever it is you're working for now's
your time
so always come back in here go listen
iron Lords podcast that is gonna be
crazy it's gonna be like a three hour
show and with that crazy night man
you're gonna be in for some good ear
listening up coming up but thank you
guys very much this this episode was a
lot of fun for one but also kind of
insane so pretty crazy but episode 59 a
last word we were up in this thing up so
thank you all and this is the last word